lucky for you guys I got family all over
in Connecticut so it's a short drive so
if they get wild and crazy I apologize
in advance
[Music]
um
just want to start off with some thank
yous real quick
the New York Liberty Carol blazikowski
um Richie adubato
San Antonio Stars
um Dan Hughes
so many people that have impacted my
life in such a positive way
um
I had a lot of thank yous and it took up
15 minutes so I I'm I think thank you
everybody
um
Cheryl uh
you know you you're up here because
you were the female Michael Jordan and
uh
yeah and I was
we didn't have Role Models so I had
posters of Michael Jordan all over my
wall
um spoon
I picked you because
you're someone who's been with me from
the start you've been up here
and from those first days of you and
Vicki Johnson giving me in my 90s style
bangs
a Beatdown in Liberty training camp
um to up here to the stage of basketball
royalty uh thank you
it's been a crazy ride
um
[Applause]
turns out I'm super grateful for those
bumps and bruises you guys made me tough
you guys gave me you made me tough and
I'm even more thankful that Carol
blazjowski when she asked you who you
guys liked you said that little white
girl
we hit her hard and she bounced back up
I didn't know then but it turned out I
was going to need a lot of bounce back
to end up here on this stage tonight
thank you to all the other
uh people to go into this class I mean
this is unbelievable to go in with all
these spurs uh Tony
[Applause]
how
Pop
um just I could go down the list I've
been fans and attempted to stop some of
you guys
um didn't most times but we tried
um
but I had to write this speech over like
I said because there were so many thank
yous and it was necessary for me to get
to this moment
um
the thank yous are endless
to try to wrap up my 46 years of my
existence in my 25 years of being either
in a WNBA or MBA Arena would nearly be
impossible too many stories and
friendships and Court battles to even
count but to all my coaches teammates
players peers
um friends and family thank you
[Applause]
so I'm not going to give you the
traditional basketball speech because
quite frankly there's nothing
traditional about me
so to stand up here and tell a bunch of
basketball junkies that I'm not going to
give you basketball is scary because we
are sick when it comes to basketball
for me it's always been bigger than just
basketball to me it's been about the
people in The Journey
growing up in South Dakota with my
parents Marty and Bev my siblings Gina
and Matt never in my wildest dreams
could I have anticipated Landing here up
on this stage in Springfield
mom dad you're not here tonight they're
in Africa doing God knows what
hunting killing animals and taking
pictures and all sorts of stuff but they
couldn't be here tonight
um but I can't
begin to express the Gratitude
um for all the necessary tools you equip
me with the values you instilled in me
and the countless amounts of time
and resources you guys have poured into
me
you four people
who am I get to call family are the
greatest foundational pieces of who I am
and where I am today thank you
[Applause]
Black Hills of South Dakota and I had no
idea my journey was going to be similar
to all those backwood hikes we went on
so many times up and down countless
mountains down to riverbeds and creeks
you learn to keep up or risk missing out
on my dad's next adventure that he would
take us on
I'm thankful for my upbringing in South
Dakota in the amount of times I heard
from people you're the first person I
ever met from a Dakota
is now a point of pride
but that upbringing was designed and
orchestrated exactly how it was supposed
to be literally I feel as though at
times I was just snatched out of
obscurity and put on this path that I
could not have dreamed up on my own
I had a poster growing up in my room and
it was know your ABCs to accomplish your
dreams and I read that poster almost
daily dreaming about becoming a great
basketball player and along with
watching the Come Fly With Me video
about 500 times
which is VHS days you had to wait five
minutes for that thing to rewind
in order to watch it again
I dedicated my life to the game of
basketball
I grew up being absolutely sure of two
things I love Jesus and I love
basketball
and no
and though it became very apparent to me
early on I was never going to fly
anywhere with Michael Jordan
my dad did give me some good advice and
he said rule the ground and not the air
and I learned that the best tools that
I'd have was two things the world of the
basketball professionals wouldn't see at
first glance
I don't look like a basketball player in
fact most times traveling with my team I
got mistaken for the water girl
I'm average height I'm average speed
on a good day
and I'm very just kind of the Girl Next
Door
type of girl
but what the good Lord didn't give me in
physical tools he gave me a double
portion of in heart grit will and a
strong mind
I'm going to use an acronym to try and
articulate my journey but most important
to me is that you know how grateful and
humbled I am to be here tonight with you
all this is so surreal to me
um
D is for Destiny I'm going to use the
word Dream It's so funny that
coach went right before me Jim Valvano
because some of his stuff was
hit right to the heart of me but D is
for destiny in so many ways I feel like
this basketball and life Journey for me
has been authored by someone else
I'm the character in my own story but
God had this path for me long before I
realized that every moment of my life
was in preparation for what was coming
next
it is clear to me that God knew my end
before my beginning and then he backed
up and began me
the psalmist said the days of my life
were written down in the book before
there was yet one of them
he made sure that I had gone through the
necessary processes
before he allowed me to reach such
wonderful promises trust and no I'm
speaking to the kids at home
and quite frankly everybody in here that
every moment especially the hard ones
are what is necessary to get you to your
destiny
R is for resilient being resilient is
both a character trait and a learned
skill the tough part about being
resilient is that you can only develop
this skill through going through hard
stuff
the amount of times I heard no or had a
door shut was the amount of times I was
going to climb through a chimney or
window I was going to bust through
something to get to where I needed to go
I was going to find a way impressing on
became an integral part of my story
so I'd like to thank you Jerry Colangelo
in the Hall of Fame committee
for opening this door for me and for
saying yes
because I was really not looking forward
to breaking into this thing and like
hanging my picture so
no mug shots
so thank you for this wonderful honor
but in all seriousness seriousness I
wouldn't change the hard parts
because the hard parts
were necessary to build the strength
needed for whatever challenge was coming
next
e is for encourage excellence
encouragements to literally give another
person courage to give someone mental or
moral strength to withstand fear or
difficulty and just like resiliency has
matured through hard stuff courage is
found in the presence of fear and
difficulty and the word excellence
because I've always strived for
excellence but I was also blessed with
being around people of great excellence
pop
I'm not going to look at you
[Applause]
you're a man of principle and excellence
I know you weren't trying to be
courageous
when you hired me
but you did do something nobody else in
professional sports has ever done
[Applause]
you display Excellence you expect
excellence and model how to become
excellent in your everyday routine and
how you go about your work
he spoke courage into me with a phone
call as I was getting ready to coach
that first summer league team in 2015.
said just be you you're going to be
great and you've texted me that I don't
even know if you know how many times
you've actually texted me that just be
you just be you just be you
and you've changed the traction of my
life
and of so many other girls and young
women
thank you I love you
[Applause]
being a trailblazer
it's a very heavy and lonely Trail at
times
it's also super exciting
an adventurous and awesome
there are many Nicks and scratches and
cuts that happen along the way and
luckily for me I literally grew up in
the Sticks
so I was ready I'm an outdoors girl
but in those times of fresh frustration
difficulty and sometimes fear I had
voices speaking encouragement into my
life and reminding me of the Excellence
that they saw in me
family friends coaches peers players
teammates in attendance tonight or at
home watching thank you for picking up
the phone thank you for picking me up
off the floor
thank you for reminding me of who lives
inside me and who goes before me no
matter what paved or unpaved path I am
on
your encouragement carried me to this
stage tonight thank you
[Applause]
my grandma's 93 she's right over there
creation
I've learned that there are two lanes to
choose from when journeying through life
a lane of appreciation and thankfulness
or a lane of taking an entitlement I
strongly encourage you to live a life of
appreciation and thankfulness
appreciation focuses on what you have
and not on what you don't have
my Aces team had a motto last year and
shout out to my ladies
I love you guys
I am grateful every day to be your coach
but go to bed because we have a game
tomorrow
[Laughter]
but we had a motto
motto no matter how much you give this
life and this game will always give you
more
so you have to give all you have
it truly is a life phenomenon it is
better to give than to receive so I
stand up here with so much appreciation
to every coach and player every
organization
that I've been with and teammate who
gave me an opportunity to play to lead
to teach to grow and to love this game
that has given me so much more than I
could have dreamed of or imagined
to Brenda and our boys
[Applause]
you guys are truly what I'm most
thankful for in this world
Kaden and Sam
like pop says you have kids nobody comes
to see you no more
Kane and Samuel are the most treasured
and greatest accomplishment in this life
for me
the other day
I was driving them to the airport
and my youngest Sam says mom why can't
you come back to Texas with us and I
said well you know I'm in season I got
to stay here I said you understand what
I'm trying to do here right he said yeah
Mom I know make shots and win
championships
I said exactly
thank you for your grace in Sharing me
with the world and supporting me and
chasing down my crazy dreams
[Applause]
whether I win or lose your hugs kisses
and love are my greatest Gifts of all
thank you and I love you
m
M is for mindset on the mission
even when the mission seems impossible
have the mindset that is unshakable and
unmovable
just because someone says it's never
been done or that it's impossible to be
done
I'm telling you I'm standing here I'm
not supposed to be here
this is not anything I could have ever
dreamed but after I did everything that
I possibly could do on my own
I know that God took what I thought was
impossible and made it possible
lastly I'd like to thank Nikki fargas
and Mark Davis
who loaned me his jet because I'm sorry
love y'all but I was not gonna miss a
game
and uh we played last night and we jump
on a plane tomorrow morning and get home
for the game tomorrow but he made it
possible for me to be here tonight so
thank you
[Applause]
he continues
Mark Davis continues as many of you in
this room continue
to invest and bet on women believing
that we have potential to change the
world
and
[Applause]
and it can't be in US versus them a male
we need everybody and if you're down for
that struggle in that fight
the only way I know how to go about
doing is putting one foot in front of
the other and walking up that hill
so
[Applause]
thank you remember your ABCs
to accomplish your dreams kiddos and
dream on thank you
[Applause]